he wears Voisin efforts for family and
you'll hear it with his brother
Christian as they are co-hosting a new
podcast called life as short with Justin
long also enjoyed his work back in the
day in dodgeball and one of the greatest
Christmas movies of all time live free
or die hard Justin long here on the Rich
Eisen show good to see you Justin how
many rich yeah really nice to be here
yeah you know you just got a look from
Brockman over there cuz this has been a
very long-standing argument about the
original diehard but let's put a pin in
that I don't want to go down that
diehard wormhole but whether or not it's
a Christmas movie all gosh just alright
don't know don't hold a pen don't know
not yet don't pull the pants yet we're
gonna get back to that
how are you sir good to see ya thanks oh
you're from Connecticut yeah and so
you're growing up fandom wood because
I'm always interested having spent seven
years in Bristol Connecticut seeing
where that mason-dixon line is in
Connecticut about baseball fan and more
football fandom yeah it's we're askin
ball fandom so well in terms of football
it was I think that's when I was a kid
the Patriots sucked so it was the more
upstate the Connecticut are is I think
we're Patriot fans by and so we were
split between the Jets and the Giants
obviously and like I was saying it was
we ended up choosing the chest by
default just because the tickets were
cheaper an economic choice - yeah same
with the Mets right you know the Mets
tickets were cheaper and so that's who I
ended up rooting for but I the Dickerson
thing I love Dickerson just because he
looked cool and the Rams I thought just
had the cool rooted for the Rams as a
kid yeah was crazy about the Rams and I
remember that game against the Bears
they lost the chin of C championship
late 80s yeah it was like brutal I used
to have a real an anger problem when I
was a kid and I'd throw tan I was
embarrassing you throw tantrums over the
Los Angeles rambling up in Connecticut
isn't that weird I never been what I
don't know if that was a rhetorical
question but yes that is weird yeah no
it was I actually giving you an answer
there and I got Dickerson autograph I
remember when I was a kid I rode away I
wrote to him and he wrote back an
autograph and it said god bless Eric
Dickerson and the I wasn't properly
reading the Kama it said god bless
kottmeier Eric Dickerson but when I was
a kid I was like that's kind of
he's great and all is God bless Eric
Dickerson
according to Eric Decker three years I
thought he was just really Aryan Jesus
yeah I mean you got to be that good you
got to believe in your own so did you
follow the fandom to st. Louis when the
Rams no no it was right around that time
I stopped following football at all
right when I started acting and kind of
got out into the world I stopped
following football for a couple years
and then I got back into it you know
when I had less to do yes and I became a
now and I'm really into it again and now
I'm back with the Jets back with the
Jets okay God well I mean hey look I
mean I don't know this could be this
could be the moment I mean Sam Donald as
the man as everybody says that he is and
he does appear to be and all the
evaluators think that he was coming in
and he had a quarterback whisperer they
got grabbed in case Adam GaSe has been
great with people like Peyton Manning
and he has survived Jay Cutler not once
but twice that's right that is that is
something that is exciting
Le'Veon Bell we're experiencing it and
levy on bail yeah you say Le'Veon or lay
beyond oh let me on bail labia minora
I don't know it could be it could be
like I could good question live well
it's on yeah yeah well that's why I go
levy on cuz when people shorten it they
go live they don't go live
that's true I mean laughs I got to use
the lab right and it's an apostrophe too
yes interesting I think lathe Bell was
somebody went to Hebrew school with you
got it me live again you cannot love him
you're really gonna hit it exactly right
that sounds like my child Justin Long
here on the Rich Eisen show okay so
you're a Knick fan as we've already
established and you're a celebrity Knick
fan which means you are not easy to say
well you are Justin I mean you're you
are you are somebody that will not say a
bad word that's right about James Dolan
I get they hooked me up Leah Giuliano
Leah or Leia
okay I just sort of like the free ticket
mix okay she's my free ticket lady so I
can't really say anything about doing
what's her name Leah Leah Julianna okay
she will never give me that ticket so I
was gonna ask you do you not go you know
he said a lot of bad things about you my
name's Don okay he's a bit vindictive
right though when I turn I don't think
that okay it's been very difficult
rooting for the Knicks under in the
Dolan era yeah and then what he did the
night of Charles Oakley made me swear
off the team for I I get it I cannot set
foot like there was in the the last time
the Knicks made the playoffs so we can
figure that out who the only time the
Knicks have made the playoffs in the
Dolan era because it was all Dave
Checketts before him so you could figure
that out I went with Marshall Faulk
actually I think they took onyx and
Madison Square Garden last time I say 13
yes it was during the NFL Draft so
that's why Marshall and I went oh wow
and then what happened with Charles oh
yeah yeah where this was going on behind
him and he watch and he didn't move and
he didn't budge he could have easily
taken care of this situation by getting
up to Charles and saying we can go to my
office after a big show and it was awful
and he didn't bat an eyelash you didn't
move once that happened cuz Charles
Oakley to me that's him Ewing he may
start Archer these are the these are the
guys after the Bernard King era that I
swore by their institutions yeah they're
to me yeah and to make that happen I
said to myself you know what I'm gonna
be a principled individual it also helps
to live in Los Angeles and not have to
worry about cities here and I go yeah
it's an easier stand to make I thought
I'm like you know what my wife is from
Boston my kids root for the Celtics and
I'm like I never thought a million years
that I would ever be okay with something
I'm James Worthy or Johnson out of those
staples and then letting him sit in jail
yeah that was it for me it is pretty
sure I don't want to get into any more I
want you to make sure that yeah whoever
you just gave a shout out that gives you
your tickets before there's another
great viral video involving to Oakland
where he kicks this how that one to
where it kicks the fan out yeah no and
he says save him for Kevin right Kevin
was his uh was his security Hirshman or
Durant one of those two may be saying
save him for Durant you enjoy watching
it on TV with Durant but look in Dylan's
defense we got to go to a commercial no
no we do not
get off the subject we'll get off the
subject who is I guess who was your
favorite Nick of all time n well I you
I'd love start IIE but what is this is
it's confusing when I was that age when
I was growing up in the start era I was
into John Stockton because I was very
tiny and white I used to be like this
you've got a stock and like if you had a
very short shorts on right now I'd think
you dad you might have gone to start an
impression it looks very Stockton
shooting that's terrible Pass I'd like
to get rid of the ball because I'm
afraid of having it I remember playing
baseball and I was so I used to pray to
God I used to it was like a I would
commune with whatever was out there when
I was out in right field I would pray to
God that the ball not come to me you
know like pleased honest to god Jr Babe
Ruth that's what kind of an athlete I
was okay so that was very unstopped and
like mommy yeah no no I didn't have that
drive at all but I identified with him
obviously just because of our aesthetic
resemblance it just yeah but so I liked
him and I'd like the the jazz how also a
cool uniforms yeah but but favorite nick
of all time I Delilah I think the Knicks
it's exciting to be a Knicks fan now you
know that the rebuilding and yeah you
really want the stupid olan rebuilding
the team don't stones he's committed
don't ones committed let's just get out
of the wormhole here just along here I
really like he's cannot stop and he's a
Celtic from right there
so life is short with Justin Long you
and your brother that's pretty cool it's
so fun why do you what is that why you
were doing this you get to do with your
brother you got some great guests
Wolfgang Puck latest is Lena Dunham Sam
Rockwell in the old Patrick Harris oh
great guests are getting been really
lucky yeah and a lot of these people are
friends men who and I get to ask them
things that I you know they had never
had occasion to ask them which us well
which is simple things thinks of other
careers how'd you get started with
Wolfgang Puck not that we were friends
he's just started opening up about his
family with very little prompting and
and and it was fascinating listening to
him getting to talk to him we didn't
mention food once
no I'm kidding I'm kidding we got into
food but things like you know what is
your what's your favorite sports team
you know for somebody who's not sure
who's your favorite Muppet you know
certain things that that TJ was asking
great questions who does that I mean we
don't just he's not the rich Ives in
social medias are as he wants to be
known but just willy-nilly
oh that's I wonder why you kept
referring to yourself as our today
there's our TJ Jefferson that's good
it's just so fun and my brother and I
get a you know we we share very similar
sense of humor and just bantering it's
been such a so it's Wolfgang Puck's
favorite Muppet was at the Swedish Chef
you know he you know a surprisingly he
knows not he loved he had a strong
connection to jasmine no he didn't know
the Muppets you know it would never have
occurred to me to get into it but it's
been it's been really fun I mean you've
been doing this for years this must be
just so I mean I love ma you know what I
just do love and you know what you're
saying is that this show we you know how
can have conversations about life and
yeah and obviously having a little bit
of sports in it is does does feed these
sports talk media you can discover I
think a lot about somebody just threw a
tangential did sports I just love having
conversations and that's what this show
was born out of a podcast yeah yeah yeah
we did thanks for taking it in for five
years and then we did it and then we
morphed it into the show so and I just
love doing this yeah yeah yeah certainly
since the other you know gig that I have
up the row with the NFL Network I'm a
host sitting at the end of a desk and I
ask questions of people and then we've
got to go to break ass there's less
pressure here is this kind of more
hanging out oh no there's more pressure
here okay
it's this is three hours of talks people
like me well Justin I'm feeling no this
is a pressureless situation for me right
now and so this is where all podcasts
Apple podcasts where anybody can pick to
sign it anywhere on where podcasts are
listening to fantastic I've got some
questions for you on your career called
Hollywood
were false here in the Rich Eisen first
one up for Justin Long in dodgeball a
true underdog story when the first
French made of rubber was thrown at you
it actually cut you open on your
eyebrows that true yes it did it did it
was that our director was a guy named
rawson thurber mmm who played Division
three football he was a quarterback and
so he would do a lot of the off-camera
throwing so fruit for the so it's never
it was not ripped torn throwing it at
you know does make sense though right
rip was no that's in the best a longer
story ripped got very upset with me once
for doing that that scene okay he
thought I spoke he thought I said
something at which you're not you know
supposed to do it because it it
interferes with the other actors
dialogue and and I was on the ground
kind of doing the motion of Kenna having
gotten hit with the with the wrench and
he said and I could tell he sees a
tional II would forget his lines and he
said dodgeball was invented by the
what's he doing I was dancing like a
monkey monkey and I thought I was a
moment where I thought oh maybe he's
just improvising because you know Benny
no were you bleeding profusely at the
time this was another referred to you as
a monkey now this is what I was doing
off-camera for him when it was his
coverage okay very good so when I was
doing my coverage day yeah so Ross and
their hurtled and my and it was it was
like a blip blip kind of thing and they
tried to close it up quickly and we just
don't have the time so that was I think
the first and only take maybe there was
another day where they didn't want me to
drive home I remember
that was we did a montage where I was
just getting pummeled with with balls
that were coming out of a I guess
pitching machine dry and you know I was
trying to get it to hit me and we could
we call these the comedy zone you want
to get a close shot of it really the
comedy zones the genitals in that and
the head well it's also the strike zone
yes if you will yeah I'm in a different
line of the strike zone sure so it hit
me so many times I they didn't let me
they said you know they said how are you
feeling Justin I said good and they said
you okay to drive and I said okay and
then I remember that this the pitching
machine was set to whatever they were
sending the dodge balls out of and then
Vince Vince Vaughn had to shoot his
stuff next and it hit him in the chest
and it came off really hard he goes
what's going on that's way too hard
that's going way too Frank you know he
got really sad moment for me because the
whole crew was like Justin's been
getting pummeled in the head for the
last 20 minutes second one for you
Justin Long you are the recipient of
Britney Spears first onscreen kiss in
the twelve thousand two classic
crossroads classic yeah thanks rich
you're welcome yeah that's true it's a
true/false thing was I her first I don't
know that she died on screen kiss I
guess oh I don't know it's her first
movie so her first movie oh you're right
yeah I don't know she could had a video
before then or not Sawyer's I think that
is sure she was very sweet she I
remember at one point our legs we were
in bed in bed and our legs were kind of
like intertwined and you know getting
ready to do this this the scene and and
she said I'm sorry my legs are a little
prickly yeah and I said whoa what are
you talking I had these grossed you can
sort of see him I have a whole mouth
gross hairy
yeah just like spider legs and I was
like and I was feeling so self-conscious
about how I looked because she was so
pretty and I was like oh no they're they
seem fine I'm sure they're fine you know
and she's no no feel and she
took my hand and put it on her thumb and
it was like a thought it was like a
smoothest thing to this day last one of
celebrity true/false is Justin Long you
appeared in ads for Apple back in 2006
so true again you and all that is it
true that you have a 15% discount on
Apple products for life no that's false
not for life I think that's I don't read
it I don't well in I haven't tried to
use it since then but I think it was
just while they were running the
commercials running I was gonna ask you
for help with the Genius Bar appointment
that's not gonna do nice I took the
other day and not that they they gave me
less dispensation but it sort of felt
like that because I I was used to going
to the Apple store and it was never like
oh look who's here it was like because
they those the people who worked there
would watch those commercials on a loop
all day you know so they I was always
met with like a mix of maybe there was a
little excitement mixed in but it was
mostly God this guy again like I'm so
sick of this face that's how I
interpreted their look to me well I've
really enjoyed this conversation we're
gonna we're gonna if you couldn't mind
sticking around for one more TV yeah
we're gonna get into the the we're gonna
pull the pin on the die hard
conversation so that'll be on the TV
side of things and we're orient you're
gonna just have to see it on the app get
a TV yeah I'll get a TV oh listen to
watch us on be our life get on the BR
live app or ever have that conversation
check out the new podcast life is short
with Justin Long co-hosted by his
brother Christian and in new episodes
every Monday on Apple podcasts or
wherever you listen at listen at Justin
Long on both Twitter and Instagram I
think it's Tuesday but Tuesday whatever
notes that means something I'm just not
going to say he's in the next one is
called know your own podcast with Justin
alright that's next on the Rich Eisen
shoot for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on VR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app